hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming through with another
math video to help you boost your score
in your math class improve your
understanding hopefully make learning
math a lot less stressful so in this
video we're going to be talking about is
how to master the unit circle so you're
probably talking about this in your
class right now and you're wondering you
know what is this unit circle and why
does it seem so challenging and I'm
gonna try and break it down for you
there's a lot of different ways to
understand this but let me show you one
easy way that I found to be very helpful
for students so basically what a unit
circle is it's a circle with a radius of
one unit so you can see if you go to the
right or up or laughter down you can see
how it's always like one okay so the
radius is one and the key to really
being good at the unit circle is knowing
your 30-60-90 triangle and your 45-45-90
triangle if you know those two you've
got it
so the 30-degree angle is right here and
to get to this point here you're going
right square root 3 over 2 up 1/2 okay
with the 60-degree angle it's reversed
you're going right 1/2 up square root 3
over 2 these are right triangles here
okay and then at the 45 this point here
on the circle is square root 2 over 2
square root 2 over 2 so what we're going
to talk about real quickly is about
reference angles and that'll make
everything a little bit easier so let me
see if I can show you so what is a
reference angle well when we're dealing
with these angles we deal with the angle
in standard position like this it's like
a spinner like say this is like an arrow
on a board game right and you you spin
it like this it's gonna spin around okay
either direction as many times as as it
does and wherever it ends up it's going
to end up in the first second third or
fourth quadrants right wherever it ends
up though what you want to do is you
want to drop a perpendicular to the
x-axis
okay so wherever that spinner goes you
always want to drop a perpendicular or a
right angled key to the to the x-axis
and the angle that's formed between the
terminal ray and the x-axis is called a
reference angle it's always gonna be
positive it's always going to be between
0 and 90 degrees or 0 and PI over 2 if
you're working in radians so what you
want to do is you want to find out what
that angle is and then we're gonna refer
back to the 30 45 and 60 degree points
on the circle here in the first quadrant
that we've already memorized so let me
show you what I mean so let's say for
example
we want to find out what is the sine of
210 degrees well the first thing I would
do is I would say all right I'm starting
over here I'm rotating 90 180 and then
30 more so 210 degrees would put us
right there okay I'm gonna drop a
perpendicular to the x-axis and I notice
that this angle is 30 degrees because we
started here 180 plus 30 more so now
when we're working with the unit circle
if we want to find the coordinates of
this point we refer back to our
30-degree angle square root 3 over 2 1/2
so that's going to be the coordinate of
this point right here square root 3 over
2 1/2 but since you're in the third
quadrant you're going left and down
right so both of these coordinates are
going to be negative but you notice that
the coordinates are the same so as long
as you know these three you've got it
now the next part of the unit circle is
how do you find the sine that cosine and
the tangent of these common multiples of
these angles well what you want to know
is you want to know that the sine okay
is always going to be the y-coordinate
the cosine is always going to be the
x-coordinate and then the tangent is
going to be the Y divided by the X okay
and the reason that works is because see
this angle here theta see this is like a
triangle right here so we've got X we've
got Y and we've got one if you find the
sine sine is opposite over hypotenuse
but anything divided by 1 is itself so
that's why it works out to just be sine
is the Y same thing with cosine cosine
is adjacent over hypotenuse but again
anything divided by 1 is itself and then
tangent tangent is opposite over
adjacent so we get Y over X our
y-coordinate divided by our x coordinate
so to finish this problem what's the
sine of 210 that's the Y value that's
just going to be negative 1/2
okay now you're probably saying well
what about radians Mario right how do I
work with radians let's do one in
radians so say we want to find out let's
just go over here we'll see the cosine
of 5 PI over 6 okay now you can do this
a couple different ways what I noticed
some students do and some teachers
promote is to think about these as
the PI over six family the PI over four
family and the PI over three family and
then what you can do is think about
multiples of that family so here I can
see I've got PI over six that's a
30-degree angle it's a PI over six
family five times 30 is 150 so I've just
done a quick conversion into degrees and
I know 150 degrees is going to be right
about there because we're starting here
and we're going this direction for
positive angles and then we're going to
just drop a perpendicular and we notice
that that reference angle is 30 again so
I say oh okay I know my 30 degree you
know reference angle I go back to the
first quadrant and I say okay I know the
coordinates is going to be square root 3
over 2 1/2 but the x-coordinates going
to be negative because I'm going left
which is negative up which is positive
right and then since we're trying to
find the cosine we say okay I want the
x-coordinate and that's going to be
negative square root 3 over 2 now as you
work through these problems you're
probably going to end up memorizing all
of these common angles and excuse me in
the coordinates on the unit circle just
naturally but in the beginning what you
can do is you can use the aid of
reference angles to help you to find out
you know trig value at any point on that
circle okay let's do a couple more
examples and I'll show you what I mean
so say we're trying to find out the
cosine of let's do a negative angle this
time say it's the cosine of let's say
it's negative 2 pi divided by 3 okay so
when we're working with a negative angle
which direction do we go do we go this
way or do we go this way well negative
angles we're going to go this direction
okay clockwise so what we're going to do
you'll notice I draw a lot of these
little circles and you might want to do
the same thing to in the beginning so I
would draw the initial ray here and then
2 pi over 3 now there's a couple
different ways to look at this one way
to look at it is we're going 2/3 of pi
pi radians is 180 degrees we're going
2/3 of that distance so we're going to
be right about there okay that's about
2/3 if we drop a perpendicular we say
how many more radians does it take to
get from here back to the x-axis well
you could see it's going to be 1/3
because that would add up to PI right so
this is going to be PI over 3 for our
reference angle and we know the PI over
3
family is the 60-degree angle 1/2 square
root 3 over 2 so that's going to be 1/2
square root 3 over 2 ok 1/2 square root
3 over 2 and these are both going to be
negative because you're in the third
quadrant you're going left and down now
we wanted to find the cosine so that's
going to be the x-coordinate so it's
just going to equal negative 1/2 so
let's take a look at one more example if
you're preparing for the AC tea I just
wanted to make a quick mention that I do
have a video course available for that
and I don't have a link for that you
know in the upper corner here that you
can check out if you're interested well
let's do a couple more examples on the
unit circle and then we'll wrap up this
video so let's say we wanted to find the
tangent this time we haven't talked
about tangent let's do a tangent of how
about 315 degrees all right so let's go
over here tangent of 315 ok so where is
315 degrees on our circle well we start
here and we're going 90 180 270 315 I'm
going to drop a perpendicular to the
x-axis and that reference angle is 45
degrees okay and we just have to refer
back to our 45-degree coordinate right
over here our square root 2 over 2 so
I'm just going to write that down root 2
over 2 root 2 over 2 but the Y
coordinates negative cuz we're going
down the X is positive because we're
going to the right we're in the fourth
quadrant here and remember tangent is
the y coordinate divided by the x
coordinate so anything divided by itself
is 1 but a negative divided by a
positive is going to be negative 1 so
this comes out to negative 1 so I hope
this helped you understand the unit
circle better if you want just a couple
other quick tips before we close is that
you could think of these points you
could reflect them over the y axis then
reflect them over the x axis and reflect
them over this way again
that's another way to you know calculate
all the different points on the unit
circle some students like to do it that
way but I like using reference angles
eventually you'll just memorize them all
because you'll do them so often but this
is a good way to start so subscribe to
the channel and I'll see you in the
future videos I'll talk to you soon